christiane germain et coprésidente du
groupe germain hôtel bonsoir madame
germaine ensemble c'est fini comment
vous accueillez cette annonce
aujourd'hui
et puis il ya des yade il ya des bonnes
nouvelles il ya des moins bonnes
nouvelles mais dans l'ensemble je pense
que on est content de voir que la maman
s'est épanché sur notre situation
est-ce que les solutions proposées sont
celles que nous souhaitions entièrement
possiblement que non mais je vous dirais
que au moins ya des choses positives qui
ont été faites je pense entre autres aux
mesures incitatives pour faire en sorte
que les québécois voyagent au québec
parce que l'aide que la fréquentation de
nos établissements que les québécois
vont fréquenter extrêmement importante
comme vous savez monsieur fillion on a
eu l'occasion d'en parler précédemment
c'est une période extrêmement difficile
pour nous
alors ils étaient les quelques mois les
quelques semaines que nous avons damb
sont une occasion pour justement refaire
un peu le plein mais aujourd'hui bien
fait ce but faisait 1400 hôtels et 300
attractions touristiques auront accès
aux prêts pour l'éléphant de roulement
est ce que c'est bien faire ça sous
forme de prêt pour vous écouter cette
épaule à cette épaule la demande de
l'industrie
parce que comme vous savez des prêts on
en a déjà pas mal on un service de dette
est quand même assez important donc le
souhait n'était pas d'avoir des près
ceci étant dit je n'ai pas tout le
détail et de la façon dont ce prêt sera
fait je comprends qu'il ya une
possibilité de radiation de 25 % du prêt
oui il semble avoir des des tarés des
taux avantageux
alors comprenez comprenez bien que j'ai
pas tout le détail mais où en premier
quand nous avons fait des
représentations auprès du gouvernement
le prêt n'était pas notre choix numéro
un ceux ci tentent oui elle et lui ont
fait
et on va essayer de bien les comprendre
et voir dans quelle mesure elle cédé ce
sont des ce sont des mesures qui nous
rendre qu'une rendre service
bon alors qu'est ce qui ne va pas
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui n'est pas là
qu'est ce que vous attendiez et qui
n'est pas venu et et comprenait que la
plupart des entreprises dont on parle
ont eu des choix drastiques lors
certains on complètement fermée mais on
ne reparle de chute de 95% de revenus 90
95 pour ça c'est très difficile de
danser situation de se tenir debout
l'industrie est une industrie qui est
habitué de demander au gouvernement de
de l'aide financière est une industrie
qui plutôt al'inverse génère des
recettes des recettes fiscales
importantes pour pour tous les
gouvernements que ce soit provincial
fédéral spam alors on s'était on s'était
attendu on se serait attendu à des
mesures peut-être à des aides
financières plus dirais ceci étant dit
je pense que la commande n'était pas
facile parce que c'est une industrie qui
est composée de plusieurs joueurs de
différentes alors de de donner là est
nécessaire à tous les différents joueurs
c'est une grosse commande
on va essayer de faire avec ce que nous
avons ici pour toutes sortes de raisons
on se retrouve dans une situation où ça
ne fonctionne toujours pas ben il y aura
toujours possibilité de se reparler
vous êtes l'une des cent vingt
signataires d'une lettre qui a été
remise à tous les premiers ministres au
canada ainsi que justin trudeau et vous
dites dans cette lettre la que la
quarantaine de 14 jours et la fermeture
des frontières ne sont plus nécessaires
et qu'il faut laisser les touristes
internationaux venir chez nous et que
les canadiens doivent pouvoir voyager
librement
c'est à ces dites vous dans le fond
ouais en fait je pense qu'il faut faudra
faut que les gens se parlent que les
gouverneurs
se parlent pour faire en sorte jeu en
fait je ne dis pas qu'ils allaient tu ne
dis pas que tout cela doit être fait
demain matin mais repartir une le
transport aérien repartir le le voyage à
l'international ça se fait pour demain
matin ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain alors ce qu'on demande c'est
que les discussions soient ouverts pour
voir quels sont les gains sont les
possibilités de repartir le tourisme
international
on pense que parce que tout se doit se
faire selon lui nouvelles règles avec
lesquelles nous avons à composer tous
les jours et nous croyons qu'il ya
possibilité de commencer à voyager puis
tout en observant et les règles la même
façon que on trouvera à l'hôtel ça va
être différent de ce que c'était avant
on va aller au restaurant très bientôt
et ce sera différent de ce que c'était
avant
alors on pense qu'on peut commencer à
voyager et ce sera différent mais est-ce
que pas un danger est ce que pointent
les dangers d'aller trop vite à un
moment où les autorités parlent de
deuxième vague puis on a vu aux états
unis les coqs qui commencent à remonter
dans les états où on a rouvert
non en fait je je je ne veux pas mais je
ne veux pas m'imposer en experte de la
santé publique loin de là mais ce que je
dis c'est que nous devons en parler on
doit pas se se rend compte et des
rencontres et des portes fermées pour
discuter de la réouverture éventuelle
des frontières il faut maintenant pardon
fait ça présentement la porte est fermée
à la discussion
ouais la porte est fermée dans les
discussions alors je pense que c'est
important de l'ouvrir comme je vous dis
on repart pas ce type de voyage comme un
peu hein
pesant sur un bouton alors je pense que
les aéroports se prépare ce sont
préparés peuvent encore implanter
d'autres mesures mais il faut discuter
de ces choses là pour penser qu'un jour
bien donc j'espère tout ça va repartir
on l'espère tous en tout cas ça c'est
clair
merci beaucoup que saint germain merci
monsieur fillion bonne soirée
bonne soirée